all right so yeah I didn't expect to
start this video like this but if you
guys saw the last video where I was
supposed to get 5 ml back to the DS that
initially gave me 101 GP he never ended
up logging in for like a week apparently
he said he's been online during lunch
times and evenings I haven't seen him
one bit but he just logged back in it's
a day after I uploaded that video so
gonna go ahead and give this guy 5
Milton because he was kind of aji about
it I did give away the 5 ml someone else
but now that this dude online I always
wanted to kind of give it back to him
and here we are so it's been about 5 or
6 days since I've last seen the guy he's
gone from level 3 to level 19 though so
obviously a little bit of progress
they're gonna go ahead and give him what
we got yeah there we go
so gonna go ahead and get on into the
money-making now hello everyone how you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day today we're here with
another video and today's video is
something I've never really done before
but after thinking of it and actually
seeing the prices of what's been going
on lately it seemed like one of the most
fun videos I could possibly make so
basically what we're here with today is
I'm going to be making some ultra
compost now as you guys see super combos
volcanic ash you put the two together
you make ultra compost you make a decent
amount of GP per one and it takes no
skills to be able to do speaking of no
skills this is why I have the group of
people behind me as you guys can see
they're just following in yeah this is
this is something else
Here I am I have six accounts that I'm
ready to go ahead and do this on so
basically this is going to be a pretty
insane video but before we get into it
I'd like to give a huge shout out to
Kayla piece from my clan Chet and I have
to give him a huge thanks for allowing
me to borrow two of his accounts along
with one of my friends the Fein Doug
what's going on buddy thank you for the
two accounts as well but with that said
basically this would be the main account
running at all but this stuff is pretty
afk to do and that's why I'm able to do
it on six at once so as far as super
compost right now it is instant buying
for 419 personally I bought these all
for 400 and as you guys can see yeah 401
so that's a pretty accurate price as for
volcanic ash right now I bought these
definitely not that high and that's
about yeah where I bought them at so
basically overall what this is going to
cost you per one is 1200 you end up
using two volcanic ash and one super
compost per ultra compost and for each
ultra compost you make it is worth 16
which is a 430 GP profit so obviously
that is a really nice profit and I'm
just going to go ahead and show you guys
how easy this really is so basically if
I just go ahead and use this on the bank
we can see just how simple this process
is all you have to do is just go here
and then press spacebar and you will
make the entire inventory now you do
have a little bit of time to afk as you
guys can see and it takes a little bit
of time and that's why you're able to
run six accounts now you could run more
than six I do believe but right now
gonna go ahead and see what I can do
with this hour we're starting off with a
total of sixteen thousand compost almost
and that should be enough for me to do
one hour with all of the accounts now
one thing I will say before we go ahead
and get on into it is super compost is a
little bit hard to buy you can't only
buy 600 per four hours now obviously if
you're running six accounts you can buy
way more than that and overall
throughout a day you'd be able to buy
each account enough to be able to run
for about one and a half hours but even
then I don't know if you'd want to do
more than an hour and a half of this per
day and I mean an hour and a half on six
accounts making ultra compost is going
to make you Bank so with that said I'm
gonna go ahead trade on all this on to
the other accounts and yeah test this
out and here we go so time to go ahead
and make them all on every account I
mean as far as this process is concerned
you could do with more accounts but the
banking is really what limits you as far
as how many accounts you can do now
obviously as you guys can see here you
have a decent amount of time but I'm
gonna go ahead and get started with this
this should be a pretty interesting and
there we go that is it so using up the
final twenty two on this account down
here and in total basically I'll go
ahead and grab the timer this took me
yeah wow that is as close as it gets so
yeah pretty much one hour six accounts
is what I was doing it with now I'm
gonna go ahead get all the stuff
together and then we'll talk a little
bit more so yeah that took me one hour
pretty much on the dot to make sixteen
thousand ultra compost so so if you take
fifteen thousand eight hundred super
compost and divide that by the six
accounts that means I was making about
two point six thousand per hour on each
account now this is depending on what
you're doing basically the max that I
would found that you were beat that you
were able to do with this basically if
you want to do it non-stop clicking just
constant banking you could do ten
accounts at lunch which would allow you
to make 26 K per hour however I went
with 16 K because that's all the
accounts I could get at the time so you
can obviously make more do
this and I'll get into that here in a
second but let's just go ahead and check
and see how much we made so I can really
just show you guys how worth it this is
so right here all the ultra compost as
you guys saw earlier they cost 400 GP
for the super compost and 400 GP for
both of the volcanic ashes that you're
going to put in so in total 1200 is what
I paid for all of this so in total yeah
that makes 19 mil was the amount of
supplies that I put into this for this
hour and then if we go ahead and check
and see how much ultra compost are now
they should still be a decent amount
yeah 1660 is what you're able to sell
them for so 1660 I put that in twenty
six point two twenty six point two I
bought them for nineteen that is seven
point two millet in one hour and these
things actually do buy and sell pretty
quickly like 24,000 are traded per hour
so I should be able to sell these
overnight and that is insane I made
seven point two mil in one hour now
obviously I could keep this method to
myself but I think it's a very fun video
to show you guys and I think that it is
actually something that people can take
advantage of whether you're someone with
one account or ten obviously the more
you have the better but even now this is
going to be worth it for you so for
those of you that are actually looking
to maximize this and wonder what it
could cap out at right now or for those
of you that are just interested you can
have 10 accounts obviously and for each
account I mean it really doesn't matter
you're going to be on 82 minutes per day
or I guess that's what it would average
out to now obviously you could just do
all the super compost or ultra compost
at one time now that is going to take
you a lot of time but more than likely
you're gonna do this kind of daily so it
comes out 8 to 2 minutes a day keep in
mind that you can only buy 600 super
compost every four hours from the grand
exchange which means you'll be making
3.6 thousand per day now with 10
accounts that means you're gonna be
making thirty six thousand obviously and
a four hundred forty GP per one that
means you're going to net about sixteen
mil per day now overall you are going to
have to buy membership for these
accounts and if you don't want to do
that in the form of real-life money
which I would imagine you probably don't
you can't buy bonds and right now ten
bonds will get you 14 days membership
for each account and it will come in at
the cost of 32 mil now overall in these
14 days the amount of time or I guess
the amount of super compost so you're
going to get will allow you for 19
1 hours of actually making the super
compost and overall basically what this
means if you do this every day for the
14 days or at least you build up the
stock to be able to do 14 days worth of
it the overall profit you will make will
be a hundred and eighty nine mil and you
will spend 19.1 hours actually doing
this money making method so if you
absolutely cap this out now you could
maybe add another account if you're
pretty quick with it but for the most
part ten accounts as the max you'll be
averaging almost ten mil per hour so
it's something that you can you know
decide upon now obviously it may not be
as good after this video but it is
absolutely insane that you need no
requirements it is such a sick money
making method now with that said there
are obviously a lot of alternatives and
a lot of things to take into account
when doing this there are so many
different variations as to how many
accounts you can have and what you could
be doing these aren't the only thing you
can make money off of in the game with
no stats they are just one that right
now is probably the eat most easily
profitable one and the one I'd recommend
to do the most but you guys can decide
on your own this is definitely something
I enjoy doing and I hope you guys enjoy
the video as well if you guys did make
sure to leave a like down below if
there's anything you guys want to see
from me going forward or anything you
want to tell me in relation to this
video go ahead and comment about that
down below on top of that subscribe to
the channel if you want to see content
as soon as it comes out in the future
but with that said hopefully you guys
have a wonderful day and a peace